so in spirit of the good place what the
pork can fans expect this youth ooh
this season is a lot of ups and downs
for us on the good place I can't really
say anything but that's an accurate
description I think well you gonna guess
the final week of filming so you have
the scope of everything that's happened
yeah what's the feeling look of it to
you and your opinion you know it's
really hard because I can't say anything
because if I tell you how it feels and
looks you'll presume where we are within
the universe which I can't give away but
it's similar to what the show has
offered in the past except I think we
went we pushed the special-effects
further this season which is really cool
and a lot of it will look more familiar
to some people because as you know we
start season 3 at the beginning of
season 3 on earth so we will experience
some earth things well for us it was a
lot of locations because we weren't able
to shoot on our sets which is where
we're used to shooting because that's
all technically the good place so a lot
of different locations around the city
and it was an interesting way to play
the characters because they their
memories had been wiped they had no
recollection of having found each other
in the afterlife and having grown from
you know sort of becoming greater than
the sum of their parts as human beings
so then in a sense for
kind of resetting with Eleanor Cheney
yes yes everything is on a reset so on
earth perhaps their relationship takes a
different Road than it did in the
afterlife there are a lot more variables
on earth that's what I'll say oh I like
being in the afterlife because there's
well first of all everything in our good
place is perfect there are fresh flowers
everywhere everything looks nice and
clean and healthy and I I really like
working with special effects I think
some of the stuff that David need Naugle
who's our VFX supervisor does is so
incredibly cool and unique so I like
working in in the afterlife
so you mentioned this that stuff was
kicked up a notch wait although I will
say our writers room perspective of what
earth is is very special because earth
is not just earth earth is seen through
the comedy lens of these writers and I'm
not gonna say they don't poke fun at us
because they do I was loving to be
honest how there was like little Easter
eggs of Parks and Rec
and there will continue to be there are
so many Easter eggs this season this was
actually the first season where I took
pictures of almost all the props and all
the set deck because it was so just
indulgent what they did and I'll just
post them when I'm allowed to when the
episode is released but they did an
incredible job especially of
representing what we are on earth I just
have this vision it's like you and I
don't think Leslie and Eleanor would
battle it out I think they'd have like a
super cool sleepover with like popcorn
and a rom-com yeah I haven't seen one of
my favorite moments listening to was
Windex yeah is there any chance any
interest in having him come back
oh there's always interest I mean he was
here today but that was playing the role
of husband because he was bringing the
kids to say hi but yeah I mean the it's
interesting the guest stars we've had
that whom we've had incredible guest
stars it depends on where we are it
depends on what universe were in when
we're on earth you know the bad place
people wouldn't Dax's character wouldn't
be able to come back there and yeah it
sort of depends on what universe they
are tethered to I guess or you can all
make it that's true that's true he could
play a couple characters um you
mentioned your girls do they get to come
out on so much because mommy has Gracie
stuff or like hmm I don't find it that
racy I actually find that the whole
construct of our show to be incredibly
wholesome I guess would be the opposite
of racy although I don't think that's
the right word for us but but good in
general I think that the undercurrent of
our show what's so beautiful to me is
that these four people exist separately
as one thing but they become greater
than the sum of their parts when they're
together
when Eleanor's molecules meet gd's
molecules they become better people
there's I think there's something really
beautiful to that so I have no
hesitation of letting my girls see
or here the show actually one thing I
really wanted to touch on this is
outside the show just are you guys
coming to Toronto are you gonna be
coming with Dex for I thinks it's a pet
it depends cuz we'd have to bring kids
so it depends but I think so that's the
plan currently yeah I think we'll be in
New York I think he's gonna do a couple
live shows in New York for armchair
expert the week before Toronto so I
think we might make it a big family trip
oh wow
well he's already you know untethered
when he's got a microphone in his hand
when he's onstage he's even more so he
is at his most relaxed when he is well
talking but especially when he's
interviewing someone so the live shows
are they're just crazy they're very
unexpected and he you know senses the
vibe of the audience and what they want
he also has like a very no-holds-barred
approach about asking things that might
seem intimate or taboo that's sort of
just who he is and you know people that
are interviewed by him know that so I
think I mean I I like watching the shows
we've had a show here in LA with Jason
Ritter and then we're about to go to
Austin and Dallas so he's starting to do
a lot of live shows now which I really
like
- yeah congratulations
thank you